I should debate whether to keep my colonoscopy schedule for 1125. I had several, I had scheduled several
months ago when I was having GI issues with erratic bowel movements, twidges of my rectum,
feeling like incomplete emptying and bloating issues have resolved, except some bloating still.
I'm wondering if I'm just inviting issues. If I do the procedure,
what are usual indications that you need to get one done? The only reason I am half inclined is
because my back's insurance has been already paid. Also my CEA and CA2729 had those slight
increases that I was told, that I told you about last week, but I don't know if that means anything.
Okay, so why would a person want to get a colonoscopy? Of course, from a medical,
and the medical answer that you get a colonoscopy to rule out any colon cancer, any polyps that are
growing, any in pocketing of your colon, any inflammation in your colon, there's all sorts of
things that will rule out and rule in and give diagnoses by doing a colonoscopy. So in that sense,
they're great to do. Firstly, I've never had a colonoscopy and I don't feel like I'm ever going to
get a colonoscopy. So is that the right thing to do? I can't say that's the right thing to do for
everybody. We have patients, they may be listening to this, that we're diagnosed with cancer because
they didn't root their routine colonoscopy. And if they didn't do it, they may have never caught it
early enough. And it was a lifesaver for them. And we've had patients that regretted doing the
colonoscopy. So it's really a difficult call. If you feel led to do the colonoscopy by all means that
you should do it. If you feel like there's reasons for it. And from a medical standpoint,
if I was a medical doctor, I would say the reason for doing a colonoscopy is that you're over 50,
everybody over 50 is supposed to get a colonoscopy. Well, I'm over 60, I still haven't had a colonoscopy
and I don't plan to do it, but that's just me. But I think there's benefits. You go to
a good GI doctor and I don't think, you know, I know you hear some horror stories of,
well, colonoscopy, I think that's like one of the hundred thousand or something. So I don't think
you have to worry necessarily about that.